يواصل العدو هذا العدوان بكل وحشيه وهمجيه
وساديه عبر جرائم القتل والمجازر المروعه
والتعذيب والتجويع والتعطيش في جريمه
اباده جماعيه وتطهير عرقي لم يشهد التاريخ
الحديث لها مثيلا امام سمع وبصر
العالم الذي بات سيقف متفرجا
ومتقاعدي من الاداره الامريكيه الشريك
الكامل والمسؤول عن استمرار حرب الاباده
الجماعيه ضد اكثر من مليوني فلسطيني من
ابناء شعبنا في قطاع
غزه 120 يوما لم يتوقف هذا الاحتلال
النازي عن ارتكاب ابشع الجرائم والمجازر
التي يندى لها جبين
البشريه بحق مدنيين عزل جلهم من النساء
والاطفال
والمسنين ومن النازحين الذين يفتقدون
لابسط مقومات الحياه الانسانيه بعد ان دمر
الاحتلال والعدوان البنيه التحتيه
والمنازل وكل شيء لتبقى هذه الحرب شاهدا
على وحشيه الاحتلال من جهه ووصمه عار على
جبين كل المشاركين فيها وايضا على جبين
المتخاذلين في تجريمها ووقفها 120 يوما
وشعبنا العظيم ومقاومتنا الباسله في قطاع
غزه العزه يسطرون اربع اروع صور البطوله
والثبات وصور الفداء والصبر والتضحيه
والعطاء دفاعا عن ال النفس والارض
والمقدسات ودفاعا عن كرامه وشفي وعزه
الامه قاطبه في ملحمه اسطوريه عنوانها
طوفان الاقصى سيخلدها التاريخ في مسيره
متواصله لشعب صامد مرابط يصنع نصره وحريته
واستقلاله القريب باذن الله
تعالى الرحمه للشهداء
والشفاء للجرحى والمرضى والحريه للاسرى
والمعتقلين والنصر لشعبنا باذن الله سنركز
الحديث اليوم في ثلاث
عناوين في ثلاثه
عناوين اولها حول اتفاق وقف العدوان ضد
قطاع غزه والثاني حول الوضع الانساني
الكارثي فيها اما الثالث فهو المواقف
الدوليه والتصعيد القائم في المنطقه
اولا حول الحديث عن اتفاق وقف العدوان ضد
قطاع
غزه لقد اكدت الحركه ومنذ بدايه العدوان
انها منفتحه على مناقشه اي
مبادرات او افكار تفضي الى وقف هذا
العدوان الهمجي على شعبنا
الفلسطيني وتكف يد هذا العدو المجرم التي
عاثت قتلا في المدني
من نساء واطفال وشيوخ ودمارا للبنيه
التحتيه والحياه الانسانيه في قطاع غزه
هذا العدو ذاته الذي يواصل حربه في الضفه
الغربيه والقدس وضد اسران الابطال في سجون
الاحتلال لقد استلمت الحركه مقترح الاطار
العام الذي تم تداوله في مؤتمر باريس او
في اجتماع باريس الرباعي الذي عقد
مؤخرا ونحن هنا نؤكد ان دراستنا لمقترح
الاطار العام المذكور والنقاش والتشاور
القيادي حوله يرتكز على اساس وصول
المفاوضات الى انهاء كلي للعدوان الارهابي
على شعبنا
الفلسطيني وانسحاب كامل لجيش الاحتلال الى
خارج قطاع غزه
ورفع للحصار المستمر على القطاع منذ 17
عاما وتامين ايواء
النازحين واعاده اعمار ما دمره الاحتلال
في عدوانه النازي وانهاء معاناه شعبنا
الانسانيه وانجاز صفقه تبادل جديه للاسرى
والاقرار الدوليه العمليه بحق شعبنا في
تقرير مصيره واقامه دولته المستقله كامله
السياده وعاصمتها القدس وفي هذا السياق
نثمن الجهود التي يبذلها الاخوه في كل من
مصر وقطر من اجل التوصل لاتفاق وقف اطلاق
نار مستدام في غزه على طريق انهاء العدوان
النازي المتواصل بحق شعبنا
الفلسطيني ونوجه رسالتنا الى شعبنا
المرابط الصابق الصامد في قطاع غزه شعبنا
الذي افشل بصموده وثباته ودعمه لمقاومتين
الباسله كل مخططات الاحتلال الخبيثه
والاجرام هذا الشعب الذي مثل الرقم الصعب
في معادلات الصراع بين الحق الفلسطيني
والباطل
الصهيوني المدعوم من الاداره الامريكيه
ومن عواصم غربيه طالما صدعت رؤوسنا
بالحديث عن قيم العداله والانسانيه
والقانون الدولي فاذا بها اليوم تتغاضى عن
جرائم الفاشيه وعن جرائم الاباده الجماعيه
التي تحدث امام العالم بالصوت والصوره
وبدعم هذه
العواصم ان شعبنا الذي قدم الارواح
والدماء وقدم الاموال ب قبر لا تحتمله
الجبال ووقف عزيزا شامخا يرفض الانكسار
وكتب في صجن التاريخ صفحات عز لا نظير لها
يستحق ان تعمل مقاومته وهي منه لتحقيق
النصر والانجاز الذي يليق به
وبتضحك وبهذا فان حركه حماس ستكون حيث
تكون مصلحه شعب نا الفلسطيني وان اولويتنا
اليوم هي رفع المعاناه عن شعبنا واهلنا
الصامدين في قطاع غزه عبر الوصول الى وقف
شامل وكامل للعدوان ورفع للحصار الظالم عن
قطاع غزه وحمايه شعبنا في الضفه وحمايه
الاقصى
والمقدسات وحمايه حقوق شعبنا الفلسطيني
على تح على طريق تحقيق اماله
وتطلعاته بالعوده والحريه والاستقلال
وبناء دولته الحره كامله السياده وعاصمتها
القدس اننا في حركه حماس على تواصل وتشاور
دائم مع كافه قوى وفصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لا سما شركاء الميدان ورفاق
السلاح وهنا نثمن ونشيد بكل المواقف
الوطنيه التي عبرت عن وحده شعبنا وتلاحمه
مع المقاومه سبيلا لردع الاحتلال وانتزاع
الحقوق وتحرير الارض
والمقدسات واننا نحذر من خطوره التعاطي مع
الاخبار والتقارير التي تنشرها جهات
معاديه حول مسار مفاوضات اتفاق الهدنه او
هئه بهدف التضليل والتاثير في حاله
التلاحم الشعبي والثبات والصمود لدى
جماهير شعبنا في قطاع غزه وستبقى الحركه
في كل المحطات وفيه لتضحيات شعبنا وخادمه
لتطلعاته ونضاله ونؤكد ان المصدر الوحيده
الدقيقه
والصادقه والموثوق لاي تطور في الاحداث هو
ما يصدر عن المقاومه
وحدها في هذا السياق ان المجرم الفاشله
نتنياهو واركان حربه من المجرمين
المتطرفين
يواصلون حمله الكذب والتضليل على جمهورهم
فهم لم ولن يتمكنوا من تحقيق اي هدف من
اهداف حربهم
العدوانيه الفشل بات يلاحقهم في كل راحل
حربهم وعدوانهم النازي على شعبنا ولا
يملكون الا الاذعان
والرضوخ لشروط شعبنا
ومقاومتنا هذا المجرم
الكاذب
نتنياهو الذي يسوق الارهاب والاجرام
بالتزييف
والكذب خرج منذ ايام في مؤتمر صحفي حاملا
كتاب كفاحي لهتلر كما ترون على
الصوره
مدعيا ان اللصوص في جيش الاحتلال قد وجدوا
نسخا من هذا الكتاب وهم يسرقون المنازل
الفلسطينيه عليه ان يعلم اولا ان هذا
الكتاب المترجمه الى عشرات اللغات قد تصدر
في عام
2016 قائمه الكتب الاكثر مبيعا في المانيا
حليفته في العدوان على شعبنا وفي العدوان
على الانر وكذلك وعليه ان يعرف ان النازيه
هي نموذج ارهابي متواضع امام الوحشيه
الصهيونيه التي نراها عمليا اليوم والتي
نظر لها في كتابه المسمى مكان بين الامم
هذا كتاب نتنياهو مكان بين الامم او مكان
تحت الشمس حسب الترجمه لانه ومن مث مثله
لا يعيشون تحت الشمس انما يعيشون في
الظلام هذا الكتاب الذي جمع فيه
نتنياهو مجموعه من الاكاذيب الصهيونيه
والتلمود حاول خلالها اثبات حق غير موجود
لهم في ارض فلسطين لكنه في ذات في ذات
الكتاب كشف عن ساديته ونظرته الاجراميه
تجاه شعبنا الفلسطيني بل تجاه امتنا
العربيه جميعا ثانيا في الوضع الانساني
الكارثي والحاجه العاجله لتدفق المساعدات
امام تفاقم الحاله الانسانيه الكارثيه
لاهلنا في قطاع غزه بسبب استمرار العدوان
وحرب التجويع والتعطيش ومنع تدفق الاغاثه
الانسانيه في كامل القطاع فان الاولويه
القصوى التي ينبغي ان تتو وحد عليها كل
الجهود الدوليه هي انهاء هذه المعاناه
الانسانيه ووقف العدوان بشكل عاجل وفوري
وهنا نتوجه بالدعوه لكل الدول والحكومات
واصحاب الضمائر الحيه في العالم الى ضروره
التدخل السريع والعاجل للضغط على الاحتلال
وعلى الاداره الامريكيه الداعمه له في
جرائمه من اجل ادخال كافه الم عادات
الاغاثه والطبيه والخدميه وانقاذ شعبنا في
قطاع غزه من الموت جوعا وعطشا ومرضا ونخص
بالدعوه قاده وزعماء امتنا العربيه
والاسلاميه ومنظمه التعاون الاسلامي
وجامعه الدول العربيه وندعوهم الى تشكيل
وفود رسميه وشعبيه لكسر الحصار على قطاع
غزه ادخال المساعدات وتضميد جراح اهلنا
الصابرين
المرابطين عملا بما اخذوا من
قرارات ان مواصله الاحتلال الصهيوني حربه
العدوانيه وارتكابه المجازر المروعه ومنعه
دخول المساعدات الاغاثه وامع انه في كل
اشكال الاباده الجماعيه بعد قرار محكمه
العدل الدوليه يشكل وصمه عار وانتهاكا
صارخا واستهتارا بالمنظومه الامميه
وبالمجتمع الدولي ويؤكد ان ما يجري فعلا
هو جريمه اباده جماعيه ترتكب عن قصد مبيت
وواضح وان تعليق بعض الدولي تمويلها
لوكاله الاونور بسبب مزاعم صهيونيه مضلله
وواهية سياسه التضييق على شعبنا ومعاقبته
جماعيا ويعد شراكه فعليه في حرب الاباده
التي يشنها العدو الصهيوني ضد المدنيين
والنازحين واللاجئين من ابناء شعبنا اننا
ندعو هذه الدول للتراجع فورا عن قرارها
وندعو اداره
الاونر الى عدم الاستسلام لهذه المواقف
والاستمرار في عملها ورد المزاعم
الصهيونيه وان لا تكون شريكه في هذه
الجريمه ثالثا على صعيد المواقف الدوليه
والتصعيد في
المنطقه يتكشف يوما بعد يوم حجم الاكاذيب
والادعاءات الباطله التي تتبناها الاداره
الامريكيه واركان حرب الاحتلال النازي في
تشويه نضال شعبنا
وشيطنتها اعتمادا على مصادر
صهيونيه تروج لاحداث واخبار لا اساس لها
من الصحه كمنظمه زكا الدينيه الصهيونيه
المتطرفه مما ينسف كل هذه الروايه ويفضح
التبني الامريكي الاعم لها اذ اخترعت هذه
المنظمه كل الاكاذيب من اجل جمع مزيد من
الاموال من
الداعمين في الوقت الذي يتواصل فيه
العدوان الامريكي البريطاني على اليمن
الشقيق وتتصاعد وتيره استهداف اراضيه
بالقصف الجوي والبحري تبدا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه عدوانا جديدا ليله امس
تستهدف فيه مواقعه في سوريا والعراق حمايه
لمصالح العدو الصهيوني الذي يجر المنطقه
باكملها الى الاشتعال عبر الاستمرار في
جرائمه في قطاع غزه ان اننا ندين
بشده الاعتداءات الامريكيه على الاشقاء في
اليمن وفي العراق وفي سوريا ونعدها
انتهاكات فاضحه للقانون الدولي وتاتي في
سياق الدعم الامريكي المتواصل لجريمه
الحرب الصهيونيه في قطاع غزه وحمايه لظهر
الاحتلال من اجل استكمال مهمه التدمير
والاباده الجماعيه التي يمارسها ضد
المدنيين والبنيه المدنيه في القطاع والتي
لم تتوقف ولم تقل حدتها ح حتى بعد
القرارات الاخيره الصادره عن محكمه العدل
الدوليه ما يدل على عدم الاكتراث الصهيوني
والامريكي بما قررته اعلى هيئه قضائيه
دوليه علاوه على استمرار عدوانه على شعبنا
في الضفه ضفه العياش ك عمليه اغتيال
الجريح على فراش المستشفى منذ ثلاثه ايام
الشهيد محمد وليد جلامه واخويه الشهيدين
الشقيقين محمد وباسل غزاوي هذه صور
للعمليه طوال حربه على غزه العدو ادعى
اننا نستخدم المستشفيات مجرمو يتنكرون بزي
الاطباء
والممرضين ويتنكر بزي
الرجال العجز الذي يحمل سله اطفال يحمل
فيها طفلا ويتنكر بزي يلبسه المشايخ انه
يعكس جرائمه الراسخه في عقله وفي مساره
على شعبنا عوده الى العدوان الامريكي ان
هذا العدوان الامريكي يعمق من حاله عدم
الاستقرار في المنطقه ويعزز احتمالات
اتساع الموا فيها ونؤكد انه لن يكون هناك
استقرار ما لم يتم انهاء الاحتلال
الصهيوني في فلسطين ووقف العدوان الامريكي
في المنطقه اننا نثمن جهاد وجهود اشقائنا
في اليمن وفي لبنان وفي العراق واستمرارهم
في استهداف العدو الصهيوني
ومصالحه وداعميه ونترحم على الشهداء الذين
ارتقوا في هذه المسيره على طريق تحرير
القدس وندعو الله ان يمن بالشفاء العاجل
للجرحى والمصابين وندعو كل قوى الامه
واحرار الى الالتحاق بالركب والمشاركه في
معركه الامه الفاصله نصره للاقصى والقدس
ولدماء الاطفال والنساء والشيوخ وهنا في
ذكرى الاسرائ
والمعراج التي تاتي في خضم معركه طوفان
الاقصى البطوليه وتتزامن مع اسبوع القدس
العالمي الذي دعت اليه مشكوره قوى ومؤسسات
ومنظمات علمائه وشعبيه في امتنا نجدد
التاكيد على ارتباط الامه بفلسطين وفي
القلب منها القدس والمسجد
الاقصى ارتباط ازلي منذ الاسرا
والمعراج مرورا بالفتح العمري والتحرير
الصلاحي وليس انتهاء بمعركه طوفان الاقصى
المتواصله نحو تحقيق مشروع شعبنا في
الحريه والاستقلال وهنا ندعو امتنا قاده
وشعوبا وكل احرار العالم في العالم الى
حشد كل الطاقات والتحرك الجاد لنصره القدس
والاقصى واهلنا في ضفه العياش ووقف
العدوان على قطاع غزه واغاثه اهلنا فيه في
الختام نبعث بتحيه الفخر والاعتزاز لاهلنا
في غزه الصابرين المرابطين القابضين على
جمر الدفاع عن النفس والارض
والمقدسات والتحيه لاهلنا في ضفتنا الابيه
وفي القدس وفي المسجد الاقصى المبارك وهم
يواجهون ارهاب الاحتلال
ومتطرف
الصهاينه اختم بالدعاء بالرحمه لقوافل
الشهداء من ابناء شعبنا وامتنا على طريق
القدس سائلا المولى ان يمن بالشفاء العاجل
للجرحى والمرضى والحريه للاسرى والنصر
المبين لشعبنا ومقاومتنا وانه لجهاد نصر
او استشهاد والسلام عليكم
تفضل تفضل تفضل
fr
commun and
[موسيقى]
thatch
ofer
ex
that
french
تفضلي بين المسؤولين في وفي
غ كتبت كما تفضلت بعض الصحف تسريبات
اعلاميه صادره من الجانب الاسرائيلي ان
هناك تباينا الموقف في قياده الحركه بين
القياده في الدوحه والقياده في غزه انا
اريد هنا ان اوضح ثلاث نقاط
واضحه الاولى ان القرار في قياده الحركه
هو قرار مؤسسي ويتخذ في اعلى هرمها
القيادي وان كل القيادات في الحركه تساهم
في صناعه هذا القرار ثانيا الاخوه في
قياده المقاومه وقياده الميدان في قطاع
غزه وقياده الحركه في غزه هم شركاء عبر
هذه المؤسسه في كل القرارات التي صدرت
وتصدر منذ ان بدا العدوان حتى اليوم وهم
كذلك شركاء فيما سيصدر من قرار من الحركه
او توجه تجاه ما يقدم من افكار لاحقه
المساله الثالثه اوضحت قبل قليل اننا ما
زلنا ندرس هذا الموضوع وطالما ان الموضوع
قيد الدراسه فلا يمكن الحديث عن تباينات
او اختلافات وانما هناك دراسه تتم حتى
الان ونحن من عادتنا ان نعلن قرارنا
النهائي بعد استكماله وبعد اخذه في
المؤسسه محاوله التشويش الاسرائيلي على
موقف الحركه تريد ان تظهر وهي التي لم
تقبل حتى الان اي مبادره بل رفضت كل
المبادرات وامعن في العدوان هذه محاوله
لتشويه موقف الحركه وايضا محاوله للهروب
من الاستح الاحقاق المطروح عليها بضروره
وقف العدوان شاملا وكاملا على قطاع غزه لن
تفيدها هذهه المحاوله وعليها ان تجيب
اجابه واضحه وان تنهي العدوان وتسحب
القوات وترفع الحصار بدون ذلك فانها تؤكد
ما ذهبت اليه المحكمه الدوليه ان هناك حرب
اباده جماعيه تتم في قطاع غزه
تفضل ياسمين رمال تلفزيون العهد العراق
السؤال الاساسي استاذ اسامه بدايه هل صحيح
هناك صفقه اليوم يتم الحديث عنها مدتها ست
اسابع بدايه السؤال الثاني هل هناك تعند
اسرائيلي بما يخص وقف العمليات القتاليه
وقف الحرب بشكل كامل هم لا يريدون وقف
كامل لاطلاق النار ما الذي يدور في
الساعات الماضيه القلي
الماضي اولا بسؤالك عن وجود صفقه حتى الان
لا يوجد صفقه
اي الاسرائيلي تعنت الاسرائيلي الذي سالت
عنه هو تعنت صريح يتكلم عنه نتن ياهو
ويتكلم عنه اركان حكومته وهو ليس سرا
نعلنه
اي ما قدم من مقترح هو اتفاق اطار اتفاق
الاطار هذا يحتاج الى نقاش وحوار لان كل
تفاصيله غير موجوده وبالتالي كيف يجري
الحديث عن صفقه بكل الاحوال نحن اكدنا
اننا استلمنا الصيغه المقدمه واننا ندرسها
واننا ن تدارسها ايضا مع الفصائل المقاومه
الشريكه معنا في الميدان وعندما يصار الى
خلاصه نهائيه لذلك نحن سنعلن موقفنا
تجاهها مع تاكيد ان موقفنا سيكون مستندا
الى تقديرنا لمصالح شعبنا وحرصنا على وقف
العدوان عليه باسرع وقت ممكن وحرصنا على
اغاثه وتضميد جراحه وانهاء معاناته
الانسانيه وهو الشعب الذي صمد وضحى وقدم
ودعم المقاومه وقف الى جانبها هل هناك اي
مساعي عربيه لتخفيض سقف ما تطلبه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بشان
الاتفاق يعني الحديث عن مساعي لتخفيض سقف
المقاومه يعني سؤال عام انا اعتقد انه نحن
الذين نملك ان نقبل او نرفض نحن سقف هنا
واضح وما نطرح ما نطرحه واضح وارادتنا في
هذا واضحه والعالم جميعا بات يعلم ان
الاهداف التي اعلنها الكيان الصهيوني في
القضاء على المقاومه او تهجير الشعب
الفلسطيني او استعاده الاسرى لدى المقاومه
كل هذه اهداف لم تتحقق ولن تتحقق وانه بعد
120 يوم هناك فشل في ذلك حتى اننا وجدنا
وزير حرب العدو يضيف هدفا جديدا ليقول ان
هناك انجاز ما المحافظه على وحده الموقف
الاسرائيلي وهنا اقول للذين راهنوا على
تفكيك الموقف الاسرائيلي عبر المصافحات
والقبولات
والتنسيق ان الذي يفكك الموقف الاسرائيلي
ويفكك وحده هذا الشارع المجمع من اقطاب
الارض الاربعه هو المقاومه والمقاومه
وحدها وهو ما تفعله اليوم مقاومه هنا بفضل
الله سبحانه وتعالى شكرا جزيلا لكم نحن
بالساعات المقبله رايحين على الاتفاق و
الامور في توتر التعنت اسرائيل التعنت
الاسرائيلي اساسي في هذا الموضوع ولكن
التوقيتات لا يمكن الحديث عنها الان قبل
ان يتم انجاز موافقه من الجانب الاسرائيلي
على شروط المقاومه عندها يمكن الحديث عن
توقيتات شكرا لكم
da